Millions of learners today
are watching videos online
using platforms such as
Khan Academy, Coursera, edX,
and YouTube.
As thousands of learners
interact with the same video
content, their
watching behaviors
lead to collective
interaction patterns.
These patterns might indicate to
points of confusion, interest,
and importance.
We introduced LectureScape,
a video player
that's powered by a set of
data-driven video interaction
techniques.
LectureScape enhances
the video timeline
to help learners identify and
navigate to important parts
of the video.
Unlike a traditional
linear timeline,
the rollercoaster timeline is 2D
with an embodied visualization
of second-by-second
navigation frequency
of all learners and
resulting interaction peaks.
It also modifies the
timeline dragging behavior
by creating a sense of
friction while dragging
the playhead around the keys.
As a result, frames near
the peaks are exposed longer
and are easier to
precisely navigate to.
In addition to collective
watching traces,
LecureScape also keeps track
of personal watching traces
and visualizes in
real time the segments
of the video that the
current learner has watched.
Clicking on the generated
segment replays that segment.
LectureScape uses
interaction data
to better support searching
for relevant information
inside a video.
When the learner types
in a search word,
the search timeline
appears below the video.
It visualizes the positions
of certain results
as well as the relative
importance of each.
Our search algorithm
rewords results
in sections of the video
where more learners watched.
LectureScape uses
interaction data
to create a visual
summarization of a videoclip.
LectureScape presents a
strip of visual highlights
below the video to
enable a quick overview
of the important points.
These are the frames frequently
watched by other learners.
Clicking on a frame plays
that point in the video.
The learner can also bookmark
their own frame of interest
and add notes, which is then
added to the highlight stream
below the video.
In educational videos,
instructors often
refer to concepts and
formulas introduced earlier
in the video, but
the referred slides
are no longer
available on screen.
LectureScape automatically
pins a relevant frame
next to that video
for a quick reference.